great victory for you today yesterday
even with jennifer you have some chances
unfortunately you were also a little bit
worse at what point how
did you feel about that game
i was a bit worried because
it's a very simple end game but i tend
to mess it up um
but thankfully everything turned out
well i made a weird maneuver with my
bishop it ended up doing nothing on a4
but after we traded everything off and
we just got into a rookie game it was
just a very clear draw
so i was content with my result
yesterday and today i'm also
let's take a look at the game's game
let's take a look at today's game take
us
through the critical moments it felt
like you got a really good position out
of the opening did you feel that way as
well it felt like so um i i feel like i
kind of forced her to put the bishop on
d4 because otherwise there were some
tactics i don't know if they worked
entirely but after
knight of six let's say i was
considering e5 and the thing about the
four pawns is i always have funny ideas
so the knight goes away to play knight
h7 yeah
yeah so if knight h5 knight takes h7
right i am not sure i'm not sure if
everything works out
um i mean here i i do think it works out
yeah it works yeah uh but it's like take
six knight d7 i wasn't super sure but i
mean it still looked nice and i was
probably gonna go for it
so
yeah
looks compelling yeah it looks it looks
quite nice
uh
yeah so she had to play bishop d4 and i
felt like here okay the bishop is stuck
on d4 so i can always take it and i'll
have the bishop player control dark
squares but it was never clear if i
should take it or not because then the
knight on d4 is very strong and i have a
lot of weaknesses in the a8 h1 diagonal
and then
you
let's keep going right so here i'm just
making like consolidating moves i'm not
allowing either b5 or d5 i feel like
that's kind of my main main
focus right now in the position
and when she went knight f5 i think she
was getting low on time
but here i felt fine because i have the
better pawn structure so
i thought that my moves now were
relatively obvious and i think she had
like uh three two minutes so
um it'll felt quite natural not sure if
i should have allowed b5 but i thought
opening the position would be okay
since she's slow on time and d6 still
weak e6 is weak
and
it's kind of like the pieces are tied up
and eventually
after some moving around um yeah just
making the pieces better after h6 now i
have the screen g4 now you have some
more weaknesses to deal with very nice
and yeah after this i went upon and i
got into a winning end game but suddenly
it took so it took so long for me to win
um
probably i didn't play the best
maybe maybe yasser and alejandro were
cursing me out you played well enough
good job
so
yeah um eventually here i guess we just
started trading everything off and
coupons is two pounds yeah
i have two so i wasn't worried
yeah
great victory for you uh talia
who do you have tomorrow
i don't know actually i think i have
rochelle
rochelle who is coming off victory as
well well talia congratulations once
again a blazing hot start in the first
three rounds keep it up thank you nicely
done talia seriously uh good control
gate right i always felt that she had
the upper hand
and she didn't really ever allow her
opponent back in once she started
winning the pawns boy then it was good
but this is the difficulty that we've
seen in chess and we've seen it already
in the games today it's so hard to win
control from start to finish very
difficult but kudos to talia and derie
young that also did the same thing today
against alice lee